[Music]
hello hello everyone
i'm jumal kali i'm a professor of
physics at the university of surrey i'm
carlo
lovely i am a theoretical physicist also
jim and i devoted
energy in in popularization and writing
for the large public
we are very different i would say in the
way we do popular science
you are more reliable than me
you take a more passionate but uh
equilibrated a distance point of view
you say this is what is going on
in a very low key way but i am engaged
in in a battle of ideas and i want to
defend my ideas
because i'm not immediately involved my
research area isn't
immediately in say looking for a theory
of quantum gravity as you are and you're
one of the pioneers of one of those
ideas loop quantum gravity
i can afford to as you say to take a
step back
and try and be neutral on the matter
you need both right absolutely we want
to kick off with
an issue with physics which i think many
people even outside of the field will be
probably aware of which is that here's
our most successful most powerful theory
almost in in all of science quantum
mechanics the theory of the subatomic
world
so powerful so successful without it we
wouldn't understand so much of the
modern world we wouldn't be having this
discussion
that's certainly our computer because we
wouldn't have understand understood and
developed modern electronics
so quantum mechanics works and it's
brilliant and it describes
our universe on a tinier scale and yet
somehow we've managed to get away with
not having
an a single agreed-upon narrative
interpretation
story of what the mathematics need uh
means
i i have my views uh uh on
what i like and what i don't like you've
been a a
an advocate relatively strongly but
mainly because you i guess you were one
of the people who who developed it
over two decades ago something called
relational quantum mechanics
now people will have heard of the
copenhagen interpretation that was
developed by the founding fathers
uh uh niels bohr heisenberg paulie but
maybe we can kick off by
you explaining what the what the
relational relation quantum mechanics
actually means
and how it differs let me start by
saying that
i i am a defender of relational quantum
mechanics it's never been contradicted
so far and
it probably has limits somewhere but we
don't know them we don't know where it
goes wrong
and still it's it is mysterious it's
completely mysterious i mean you read it
you use it
but then if you ask what is it saying
about the world
uh we get confused and there is a a
remarkable difference of opinions in the
community
each one of them has a very high
philosophical cost they ask us to
realize that something we thought before
was wrong
there is more in the world than what we
just see
uh maybe there are hidden variables that
we can never measure
maybe there are other words maybe there
is a so
the question now is which which
perspective is more useful
and uh the debate is open and i think it
has been changing
the relational quantum mechanics you you
mentioned on which i'm being involved
is probably the the young kid on the
block is much
younger than the others and it's very
close to copenhagen
into the standard textbook in fact i
would say is the closest
tentative solution of the problem to the
to the textbook one
the textbook what you write in textbook
is that you study a quantum system but
you're outside it you're in a classical
world so no quantum mechanical world
so you described how the system affects
you the classical world how it affects
your apparatus what you measure what you
see
um and it works very well and the really
the mystery is
yeah but what about the classical world
i mean isn't quantum mechanic
as well aren't we made of atoms
and aren't we quantum as well so how can
we
have a theory that explain how quantum
stuff affect
us classical stuff if we ourselves
now relational idea is very simple and
it's the following the theory is not
telling us how a quantum system
affect the classical world the theory is
telling us how a system affects any
other system any two physical system
that don't need to be human don't seem
to be memory to be classical anything
if you want to know how one effect
affects the other you use quantum
mechanics
and this is intense because
instead of thinking of system with
properties you only
are asked to think of of systems with
relations with others
so in a sense systems by themselves
don't exist they only exist in the way
they
they affect the other that's india and
it has a technical side it's uh i'm
defending
it and the main argument in favor of it
i have
is that the alternatives are even worse
it sounds very much like relativity
theory in the sense that you know
what you see depends on your frame of
reference depends on
you as the observer and so if i see
two events happening uh i may not see
them in the same way that you would
relational quantum cache also
said that if you and i are observing a
quantum system we don't necessarily have
to
report the same thing exactly that's
amazing
that's the main thing so so that is in
that sense it's quite
similar as you say to the copenhagen
interpretation in that
you know as neil's ball would have said
it's not about how the world is it's
about what we can say
about the world it's very similar to
copenhagen it's very close to bohr
boss says you i cannot look just a
quantum system itself
the quantum system and the apparatus and
i'm just trying to say okay a hundred
years have passed that's
true but it's not just an apparatus it's
a quantum system and any other system is
interacting with
yeah if they want to study is that the
system i have to refer it to
another system again jim let me turn the
question to you what is your attitude
because uh i think
everybody has an attitude with respect
to point of mechanics it's a little bit
like what's your religion
yeah that's right it's it's interesting
isn't it and we try
as particularly as physicists to say no
you know we are
objective we don't you know follow
physics isn't an ideology you know it's
it's
about you know scientific method and so
on but you're right people do have
um so as as i'm sure you did as probably
you know all physicists of our
generation we were trained we learned
quantum mechanics uh following the
standard the copenhagen view the
textbook view
while i haven't fixed on one particular
interpretation to say that
yes it's definitely many worlds there
are many universes
this is you know i subscribe to this you
know dogmatically
the one of you i do feel strongly about
is that
it cannot simply be a matter of
philosophical taste
or choice how we think
nature is you know we have an
embarrassment of these different
interpretations the way we
explain what the math tells us about the
world whether it's copenhagen whether
it's relational whether it's
quantum bayesianism whether it's many
worlds whether it's
de broglie bone there's all these
wonderfully named exotica
all strange in their own way all
easy to argue against from another
perspective because every one of them
has some strangeness in it
um my view is that one of them has to be
right
and the others are wrong because i think
nature behaves in a certain way
independently of our debates and
arguments and discussions either there
are parallel universes or there aren't
you know either there are hidden
variables or there aren't either the
universe is deterministic or is
indeterministic
um i tend to be if i if i'm asked to
sort of
pick one that i prefer i tend to to
prefer sort of the
the more uh realist interpretations that
there's an objective reality which i
guess probably goes against
relation quantum mechanics because that
would say that
you know an atom doing what it's doing
it's doing something
you know regardless of you and i having
different views on it
it's doing something and quantum
mechanics should
tell us what it's do what it's doing
it's been behaving quantum mechanically
before
humans arrived for you know life emerged
four billion years ago on earth
uh and so it can't simply be
a world that somehow um conjured into
into or crystallized into reality by
our observations um so
it may be that sits underneath you know
maybe relational quantum mechanics
is all quantum mechanics can tell us it
can you know
how how we perceive the world but maybe
underneath that there is some objective
reality that we may or may not
ever one day reach but i sort of feel
that
it has to exist there independently of
our observations
but more in the direction of the bloody
bone so there are these wave functions
and there are also particles or in
direction of many walls
well i think stirred i think more in the
direction of de bruy bone because
um metaphysically i find it hard to buy
into
or any infinite number of realities
coexisting just because
an electron on the other side of the
universe decided could
go left and right and the universe split
into of course i have
i know de bruyne has its own problems
but
it has a certain appeal to me
aesthetically
but i know that's not the way we're
supposed to do physics
i think that the it will the debate is
not
blocked i think it is evolving um
some perspective has been i've been
abandoned uh some
way of thinking i'm not fashionable
because they were not working
one thing might happen is that some
perspective works
better for going ahead yeah yeah
we want to do quantum gravity right and
uh maybe one works better for doing
quantum gravity and then and then we
somehow
find it fruitful so to continue watching
this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas